one after the other it was like being
stabbed and stabbed and stabbed again
over and over again it's unbearable
for Nobel five years could well be five
minutes
he lost six members of his family
overnight
his mum sister brother-in-law and nieces
you know there's that big gap that will
never be filled you can't replace
something that was so unique
so memorable and that will always just
be a memory now
the grenfeld tower fire claimed the
lives of 72 people
survivors and the bereaved expected
prosecution arrests
for what they got instead was five years
of an inquiry
and now 312 days and 300 000 documents
later the inquiry is over
there's a lack of clarity now but the
Chairman's report in a year or so will
give answers and recommendations
the council for the inquiry have
themselves said that the companies have
taken part in a merry-go-round of buck
passing to mean that they've been
deflecting blame now this process in and
of itself cannot determine civil or
criminal liability but what it can do is
pave the way for both the question is
will it
Barrister Imran Khan says there's
evidence that race and unconscious bias
are at the heart of what happened at
grenfell there are 85 percent people
from Minority of the communities who
died in the ports of the fire at
grenfield we've heard accounts about
race affecting people's treatment and I
think that is the clear definition of
institutional or structural systemic
racism and this inquires got to deal
with it it's the elephant in the room
yep come towards me but for paulus while
the details do matter they won't bring
back his five-year-old son
uh I miss all of them all of his active
his things
you know when uh
one of the things I missed is uh
well welcome me when I I came to the
hall
so now videos like this keep his memory
alive
especially for his other son he doesn't
want to forget him so he's asking me can
I listen his voice
his voice
a parent who had to bury his child
time they say is the best healer for the
bereaved but sometimes it isn't enough
for now though all families can do is
wait
Saba Chowdhury Sky News West London